sono tutti ragazzi e bevete questo nuovi
d'ora ragazzi allora io sono eccitato
come una pigna perché oggi dal tar è
uscito da un paio di giorni ma chi se ne
frega oggi stiamo per giocare a un gioco
che è stato fatto dagli stessi creatori
di a way out che è la serie del mio
canale che ha avuto praticamente più
successo della serie che mi chiedete
tutti no mamma mia a voi out di ricordi
bellissimi eccetera è perché era bella
la serie diamogli auto una delle
migliori serie del canale perché c'era
il sottoscritto ma anche l'incredibile
unico ciccio per i loro amico mio sei
pronto perché questo adesso mi sto per
prendere da via a un'avventura pazzesca
le fa ero sono pronto io la chiamo parte
lo so ora basta la grand hotel pur
sempre ma che forse si stabilizzano
poteva essere lei non ho capito devo
andare all in di vista cosa che ha detto
per del fiscale semplificato to brother
finale al nazista
da questa brutta chirurgo
ma che carine soste bambole voglio
anch'io come se fossero chiamati zack e
cody sarebbe stato ancora meglio
vai subito sul personaggio col naso qual
è il tuo è perché è da fare solo questo
va bene allora io inizierò con chicchi è
codici sono pochi ma sei sicura perché
c'è il codino
no non so porca vacca mercato joystick
api stanno separando poi parole
è probabile però sicuro però che magari
norina che tristezza
comunque per un bambino deve essere
incredibilmente brutto
intanto i due pezzi di merda con quanta
cattiveria dei mesi preso
vabbè vabbè che spider man ma dovrò ma
lo sai che questa la vedi questa cosa ti
sta cosa qua che gli cresce letali io
sono sempre avuto l'ansia liste cosa in
america ma ora sarà un antica tempo
dietro razzi ma che anzi ad onna da
falegnameria ma crea una visione e noi
prendiamo vita goccia a goccia tocca al
corso e si e si deformano guarda a ramon
chao ormai sei le scrivi le trame sei tu
che fai aspetti solo che sia io a dire
chieda di giocare ma mette un film è
possibile mio padre ma fini scusa cioè
fammi capire loro sono i genitori
non avevo capito niente
io pensavo loro fossero personaggini
piccoli dei giochi che prendono vita
invece no loro sono le anime dei
genitori
eccoli cioè io vedo la tua visuale e la
mia c'è questa roba qua ragazzi e falsi
cosa stai facendo è bellissimo non so
neanche come tu faccia bene va bene
cos'è sta roba da e bellissima sta cosa
non è il pagano è troppo bello oddio
passo posso girare stoppa hai avuto è
veramente figo stai voto è come a way
out visto uscire di prigione ma bisogna
uscire alla farina e falegnameria a cena
le ba opera in due metà e non sono tanto
vale non a schiacciare coletto astori
pensa che gioco al computer da 60 anni
hanno capito qual è la ypsilon manco che
ti ha fatto però ricorderò se posso dire
questa roba qua che continua la loro
storia è che loro lavorano insieme poi
alla fine si rimetteranno insieme perché
si chiamano di nuovo asus lancia melo
tipo che si va beh se arrivano scappare
di nozze che abbiamo di attaccarlo
buttandolo giovane salviamo books of the
east anch'essi bravo lei schiaccia
essere il che è entrato nel deretano a
noi è salito purtroppo è come fai
ma se il fenomeno giochi ma le righe le
foto sopra di noi
stai già tutto come cacchio eh vabbè ma
è bastato a arrivo
vado ma la ok alcol accederai benissimo
assieme chiacchio sto entrando questi
sono i cavi di internet attenzione
dovrebbe essere quello dove la sinistra
ho chiesto così dove l'abritro l'uno via
siamo troppo bravi e adesso ha chance
anticipo la sua smerilli ok dov'è quel
coso e fastidio vieni qua perché
facciamo anche utili bravo perfetti
siamo deficienti prossimo 31 dicembre
wow va bene una margine ancora dei
comunque euro è formato sessi ma per
capire c'è qualcosa la corrente lo
stacco perché secondo me serve aspetta
di è vero ma non l'ho attaccato in
realtà un occhio ciapa questo è certo
ora eccolo occhio o merda asi bellissimo
titoli a chi ne way option sta roba
sì sì sì rallentava il tempo ho preso
madonna rega è stato fighissima questo
bordello e poi sono tornati qua fine ce
l'ho fatta ma nostra figlia ci può
vedere così o no che questa volta non ho
capito ora svenderebbe ray penso quello
vero ma vero 12 anni per aprista cosa
basta lillo
ecco lillo home è grazie al nilo c'è
voluta però un po rude ma d'altro mentre
parlano invece l'audio merca non so
perché orca vacca ci apriamo il
segretario gran boksic urla battere ma
in tutto questo nostra figlia non bene
sta roba eh no è il secondo membro tv è
stata effettuata strana per lui
ottimo
[Musica]
o mamma mia che blocca gli album come la
gata secondo me boss fight subito ma
dovevo andare cosa non c'è un bomber da
telethon e vabbè
no sono cascato nella melma c'era solo
una roba da non fare quella bene non
sono molto bravo nel classico sestese
vedo molto bene
quello però c'è sempre leggono
l'aspirapolvere centro o tutto ok e sono
entrato nella bocca forchetta occhio
e vabbè ma mai sei un fenomeno l'hack è
male le vga ho capito noto ha vinto in
molti hanno visto fare nel trailer
guarda entraci fino a dire meno ciao
ok centro io che ne so ecco le vigiliare
il coso tirargli un oculata tirana con
la faccia da bravo ce l'ho fatta per
figo e alla fine lascia stare insieme a
destra e sarà rosa primavera
collaborazione mai visto che mettono
veramente si è detto lui ritorno intanto
dopo che è veramente sono sempre cacchio
è iniqua ok c'è tutto sto casino
famiglia alto dove vi daremo un altro
nome immaginaria perché non può essere
così grosso sly quartiere infatti dopo
la melma casa la melma sono poi quasi fa
la stessa cosa si ok
anch'io che baila ok ecco il mi ha
spinto perché quello spina prova è il
contrario guarda sollevano grazie
dobbiamo collaborare per andare avanti
sostanzialmente vuoi ce la faccio anche
sveglia che non so che c'è chi ha fatto
questa roba alto voltaggio veniva a uno
deve fare dal contatore ok allora per
fare qui ha poi inizia a diventare
difficile però inizia diventato ha tolto
questo così passi poi passare ma le
lettere per uscire adesso possiamo fare
che schiacci quello che è poi nell'altro
con ricordi aia porco demonio nell'altro
subito vado ce l'ho fatta grazie a tali
brava sioli però occhio
aiuto mi ha fatto per noi sud dove
stiamo fine eva bel casino
ok
quanti cacchioli aspirapolveri esistono
il suo posto
vabbè che 70 si regolava il male adesso
ok
praticamente la stessa cosa ecco ci
siamo quasi
se volete possa giocare con un joystick
solo faceva le stesse cagate ok ho visto
cose molto più dangerous di libro
giochino sta roba
anzi tiro io ma che successo tranqui
tranquilla sias ha visto quanti faccenda
lavativa subito ciao mi possa aggrappare
l'aspetta ho capito ci puoi aggrappare
rimanere aggrappato a
ok tipo prince of persia ecco qua ce
l'ha fatta
ps ma perfetto a modo fare qua aspetta
sì sì sì triangolo sta arrivando della
roba non so dove
ayew che è successo però aperto la porta
ho chiesto di farlo tu sai chi attacca
più in alto toccati altri temi
bravo esattamente il bravo hai via c'era
un buco
e vabbè
abbiamo rischiato pochissimo a 120
chiari cosi vyver ginami cosi grazie ok
ok bravo
faccio una leva aspettando vai lì quassù
c'è una cosa della luce pirelli
annuncerà materiale da calci ma l'ho
fatto mi sa che stiamo risalendo se con
casi alla fine però vedo la fine della
sfida polvere ci siamo si sa che non
percepiamo è fatta è fatta dura si è
fatta più magro ok figo però vai pure io
adesso stiamo risalendo tutti i pezzi
occhio
no veramente vi voglio fare sta cosa
voglio vorrei che esistesse sta roba per
farla ok a buy tourism han che di nuovo
effetto non mi chiedere che devi fare
lanciati yes
e ora le vigilia che questo affare non
sopra da rifiutare cosi di buttare giu
ok dall'altra volte che ci si incanala
l'aria è perfetto per gli uffici sono
stato già perché mi devo cominciare a
mai una vagina via tranquillo veloci
della luce che ho fatto
yes posizione del fare la cacca aiuta
sempre
let's go e adesso allo spingerli anche
perché devo schiacciare quel coso così
tutti i picchi di sopra non ha
significati a sopra e poi realmente
salta sui costi ricordo rai la rai santa
ci non li saltare sul serio la bora che
tft aspira capito vai a ok scusa fan di
abbinare fatte bene sopra sopra le fatti
ma non quello l'altro non li ferma
improperi questo questo qua borsa
sinistra sarebbero solamente fai così e
di alzo felice deve essere fatta a yes
vai adesso deve cambiarsi in coso
come sempre se magari aspetto che sia
adesso è cambiato tutto ok e le dio gli
ex questa rimane la funzione tra
barbarie che è roba ed ebbero poi finire
la vita pista cadore dove allora credo
però che aspetta che ti ho lanciato
qualcosa ha la palla
riprendi riprendi riprendi riprendi col
a fare fino a di fare ok preso
progressive ti butto nelle mele vengono
troppo filo che ai fini che poi non
faccio colpire con l'affare sia base al
massimo
vai vai col piscina ma è bellissima sta
cosa ma che figata
dunque sono i così che puliscono per
terra ma volano non so come sia
possibile
ok bene abbiamo usare come piattaforma o
ci avevo fatto a me brother 12 ore e
adesso ci sarà boxe fight è ormai
scritta starò e direi azmi la torre si
chiama non ho parole è tipo crash
bandicoot devi cambiatevi di schivare
goya porco demonio
c'era un posto interventi aspetti che
faceva la stessa cosa
mai sopra e manesca di succhiare sono
alcune perché era vicino
e appunto taglia che male si sta
spaccando delle danaidi lontani perché
qualcosa come sei lontano e forse già
così riesco mai grandi grandi grandi mai
perfetto
ok lontani così ci colpisce parlare che
separa ma infatti è orrendo aspirato
aspar ha fatto che occhio orribili che
le bombe spaccagli kubra voci rischio
però la paura aiuti canale mamma ci sono
delle mine tropez vabbe
mi sa che siamo morti lo stima la merda
cioè trick estimatrice terminator valido
no no va bene ok no mi sono sparato io
mi sono ri sparato
io mi sono fatto troppo tardi però è sì
questo no invece un po destina gli spara
bella è levato un ostacolo lancio delle
pietre grosse aspiratore non mi fai
paura poi tutte queste le bombe che vuoi
ma aspira tornei mai
naturalmente mentre dai che ce l'abbiamo
fatta mai spaccagli culo è finita yes
farei vini equa ma è bruttissimo rosa
già pasti cosi e fagli di risucchiare me
stesso allora premier sempre fianco
sempre si angolo mischiato a che che
bruttissima roba ma no ma ragazzine è da
incubo si è mai sottratto i suoi orchi
bova bar sport a è vero perché se tu
metti un cosa dell'aspirapolvere dentro
al piave stesso esplode dono siamo
cascati con un po di lag però vabbè sono
ritornati quadro rifacciamo tutto
martello è un bullone a un martello dato
è pesantissimo cosa fare come faccio a
portarlo sulla schiena come se niente
fosse a tuba gli ho fatto il chiodo e tu
lo metti ok ma non è tra mano io stimo
trovarle prodi riprendo il lodo pacco e
spari le cose io l'esame per aspetta fa
lo spaccone robben è quindi ragazzi
questo era il primo episodio di it takes
two è veramente fatto benissimo c'è
parete preleva persone che la pari a way
out che era un capolavoro quindi per
forza ringrazio ball ciccio perché un
paio armi questa avventura e come sempre
ci siamo forse episodio arriva molto
molto presto perché voglio assolutamente
finirlo con ciccio e registriamo tutti a
man e quindi non vi preoccupate che
tranne peter e l'altro passano massimo
34 al massimo george massimo massimo di
schede a calare lasciato momento qua
sotto
decidiamo come sempre
salvo servino bello ragazzi
[Musica]